okay let me get right into audience
questions we've gotten so many of them
so many things are going on a lot of the
topics are understandable and
predictable and I want to dig right into
them first one David will the protests
and civil unrest be good or bad for
Donald Trump in terms of his approval
rating and his reelection chances in
November listen the answer is very much
like it is on coronavirus Donald Trump's
response to coronavirus was a failed non
response Donald Trump's response on the
civil unrest has been worse than a non
response we have a we have unrest that
was that started with what was seen as
the brutal unlawful killing by police of
George Floyd and Donald Trump tweeted in
his bunker all weekend okay he was in
his bunker for a few hours tweeted from
the White House all weekend including
from the bunker on Friday night only to
come out on Monday and say we need more
police force we need to further
militarize law enforcement right so the
worst possible thing that he could come
out and say but the trumpet's defended
him on coronavirus and the trumpets will
defend him on his most ly will defend
him on his response to the civil unrest
this works in the short term I don't
believe that this will work in the long
term so like with everything else what
matters is how long is this going to go
on take coronavirus as an example failed
response completely failed response
numbers are now starting to improve
states are opening up whether this will
lead to a huge resurgence of the virus
or not we don't know what will be
happening in September October into the
November election we don't yet know but
Trump pretending everything is fine even
when it's not only works for so long six
weeks ago Trump said no more these press
briefings with doctors I'll do CEO
roundtables little all that stuff and
just basically pretend this is a
business situation rather than a medical
situation in the immediated sort of work
that did get a lot of trumpets and
right-wingers saying we're back and
we're reopening and sort of disconnected
from the realities we still had 15
people die in a single day from
coronavirus a few days ago so if that
continues Trump's
she is not going to work similarly on
civil unrest if protests continue for
months through the summer as coronavirus
doesn't go away and Trump seems to be
unable to control it deploying the
military happens with increased
frequency and it is seen as an
authoritarian move from wannabe baby
dictator Trump a lot of people are going
to react negatively he will still have
the core trumpets that support him no
matter what he does as he said if I
could you know I could shoot people on
Fifth Avenue they'd still vote for me he
could send soldiers to shoot people on
Fifth Avenue and many people would still
vote for Trump but it is not going to
appear to be a strong Trump it is not
going to be a trump that appears in
control even you know earlier this week
the staged photo op propaganda event at
st. John's Church in DC where Trump had
protesters tear gassed and dispersed by
police on horses so he could hold a
Bible up the wrong way like clearly held
the Bible in a way no one who holds a
Bible would ever hold a Bible just to
get that picture yeah some people liked
it and there were some video at its done
of it on Twitter where it's you know
with inspirational music and look at the
great president Trump it's not going to
work for that long if the protests
continue the buck at some point stops
with the president even Trump said when
there were protests under Barack Obama
nothing like what we're seeing now then
it's Obama's responsibility and of
course it's different rules for Trump we
know that but I do not believe that over
the long-term coronavirus continuing is
not going to be good for Trump no matter
how he propagandize is because there are
factual realities on the ground a
continued disastrous economy with 25
percent of the labor force that was
working before this started 11 weeks ago
unemployed it's not going to be good for
Trump disastrous GDP numbers coming out
in late August it's not going to be good
for Trump no matter how he propagandize
is in much the same way if the headlines
continue to be things are out of control
yeah you'll have Republicans saying oh
it's all democratic run they'll say
Democrat runs
cities that are having a problem well
urban areas are disproportionately
democratic it doesn't you know the
cities that are having problems are
mostly run by Democratic mayors and the
cities that aren't are as well because
that's the way it works we have an urban
rural divide in this country those
talking points will work for a little
while but they are not going to work all
the way through to November if the
unrest continues and Trump seems that to
be the flaccid impotent guy that he is
who can't take control of a situation
who can't be presidential who can't
reduce tensions and rather in flames
them I think it will dramatically
backfire and by the way Joe Biden is no
miracle of progressive values you all
know that but Joe Biden's been giving
some pretty sensible speeches about the
unrest and about coronavirus over the
last 10 days they've widely not been
covered by corporate media for all of
the apoplectic shouting about liberal
corporate media they're covering what
Trump says and does and they're not
covering what the Challenger who could
be president in only what is it now
seven eight months he could be
inaugurated they're not covering what
he's saying and he's making a lot of
sense I mean even a lot of the never
Biden people that watch the show wrote
to me over the last few days saying you
know I'm not I've got to vote for Biden
you know clearly these guys are not the
same the last week has proven that and
Biden's being reasonable imagine if
corporate media actually showed what Joe
Biden has been doing and saying I think
it would be even more disastrous for
Donald Trump